Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，因为 Eglinton Crosstown 轻轨列车正在进行测试。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. If I were an Indian, I often think that I would greatly prefer to cast my lot among those of my people who adhere to the free open plains rather than submit to the confined limits of a reservation, there be the recipient of the blessed benefits of civilization, with its vases thrown in without stint or measure. The Indian can never be permitted to view the question in this deliberate way. He is neither a luxury nor necessary of life. He can hunt, roam, and camp when and wheresoever he pleases, provided always that in so doing he does not run contrary to the requirements of civilization in its advancing tread. When the soil which he has claimed and hunted over for so long a time is demanded by this to him, insatiable monster, there is no appeal. He must yield, or like the car of Juggernaut, it will roll mercilessly over him,
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。我常想，如果我是印第安人，我宁愿选择与那些坚持在自由开阔平原上生活的族人在一起，也不愿屈服于保留地的狭窄限制，去接受文明那毫无节制、强加于人的所谓“恩惠”。印第安人绝不被允许以这种审慎的方式看待这个问题。他既不是生活的奢侈品，也不是必需品。只要他不违背文明前进的步伐，他可以在任何他喜欢的时间和地点狩猎、漫游和露营。当他长期占据并狩猎的土地被这个对他而言贪得无厌的怪物索要时，他没有任何申诉的机会。他必须屈服，否则，就像贾格纳特（Juggernaut）的战车一样，它将无情地从他身上碾过，
destroying as it advances. Destiny seems to have so willed it, and the world looks on and nods its approval. So, Dominic, that was George Armstrong Custer. God almighty. The flamboyant darling of the United States in the 1870s. Yeah. And that was from My Life on the Plains, or My Lies on the Plains, as Major Benton called it. And it was published in, is it a magazine called The Galaxy or a newspaper?
在前进的过程中摧毁一切。命运似乎就是这样安排的，而世界则在一旁点头表示赞同。那么，多米尼克，刚才那是乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特。天哪。1870年代美国浮夸的宠儿。是的。那段话出自《我在平原上的生活》（My Life on the Plains），或者像本顿少校所说的那样，是《我在平原上的谎言》（My Lies on the Plains）。它是发表在……是一本叫《银河》（The Galaxy）的杂志上，还是报纸上？
No, it was a kind of magazine, I think, a kind of journal. It's a journal. Anyway, so that was in 1872. Yeah. I mean, this is articulating his paradoxical approach to, I guess, what he would call the Indian question. It's hard to make out the paradox there, Tom, because I don't believe that Custer spoke like that. I think he did. Oh, well.
不，我想那是一种杂志，一种期刊。是一本期刊。总之，那是1872年的事。是的。我的意思是，这阐述了他对所谓的“印第安问题”那种自相矛盾的处理方式。汤姆，很难看出其中的矛盾之处，因为我不相信卡斯特是那样说话的。我想他是的。哦，好吧。
He's a kind of jaunty, you know, roaming the plains kind of a guy, isn't he? That was very jolly. And I don't think he was. It's not a very jolly subject, is it? No, it's not. He's talking about the car of juggernaut running over the Native American. All right. Well, maybe I should do it again.
他是个那种轻快、你知道的，在平原上漫游的家伙，不是吗？那段读得非常欢快。但我认为他并不是。这不是一个很欢快的话题，对吧？不，不是。他在谈论贾格纳特的战车碾过美洲原住民。好吧。也许我应该再读一遍。
No, God, no. You can do it again for me privately, Tom, but not for the listeners. I just wanted to convey a sense of his vibrancy. Yeah. So that first bit is often quoted that Custer said, you know, if I were an Indian, I would want to be roaming the plains, not on a reservation. But then, of course, he goes on to say the Indians should not be allowed to view the question this way, that he's standing in the path of civilization, the Indian, as he would
不，天哪，别。汤姆，你可以私下为我再读一遍，但别对着听众读。我只是想传达他那种活力感。是的。所以第一部分经常被引用，卡斯特说，你知道，如果我是印第安人，我会想在平原上漫游，而不是待在保留地。但随后他当然继续说，不应该允许印第安人这样看待问题，因为他挡在了文明的道路上，正如他所说的那样，自然必须顺其自然。正如我们将要看到的，你知道，我们上次谈到坐牛（Sitting Bull）和美国将军对美洲原住民的态度时稍微提到了这一点。这其中有一种社会达尔文主义的成分，实际上我们稍后会再谈谈这一点。完全正确，是的。所以无论如何，卡斯特回到节目中真是太棒了，不是吗？
put it, and nature must take its course. And as we will see, you know, we talked a little bit about this last time when we were talking about Sitting Bull and American generals' kind of attitudes to Native Americans. There is this sort of Darwinist element to it, and actually we'll talk about this a little bit later. Completely, yeah. So anyway, it's brilliant to have Custer back on the show, isn't it?
因为上周我们离开他时，他已经在沃希托河（Washita River）丢尽了脸面，屠杀了许多夏延人，事后表现得非常、非常糟糕。在过去两集里，我们介绍了平原印第安人、疯马（Crazy Horse）和坐牛。我们以一个激动人心的悬念结束了节目，汤姆，就是坐牛发现卡斯特正在黄石河上向他推进。所以这一集将讲述那次初次会面以及卡斯特前往黑山（Black Hills）的远征，这为他们后来在小大角战役（Little Bighorn）中的大决战铺平了道路。但我们把卡斯特留在了1860年代末。实际上，与此同时他一直在漂泊，不是吗？他只是在闲逛。他去了芝加哥。他去了密歇根。
Because last week we left him having disgraced himself at the Washita River, having massacred a lot of Cheyenne and behaved very, very badly afterwards. And in the last two episodes, we introduced the Plains Indians and Crazy Horse and Sitting Bull. And we ended with the exciting cliffhanger, Tom, of Sitting Bull discovering that Custer is advancing towards him on the Yellowstone River. So this episode will tell the story of that first meeting and Custer's expedition to the Black Hills that paves the way for their great showdown at the Little Bighorn. But we left Custer back in the late 1860s. And actually, he's been drifting a bit in the meantime, hasn't he? He's just been hanging around. He's gone to Chicago. He's gone to Michigan.
他和妻子利比（Libby）大吵了一架，我们可以从他们的信件中看出来，因为他给她写了信，说……他的眼睛被泪水模糊了，他非常抱歉，他让自己失望了。是的，他做了一些事，我们不知道是什么事。我不会试图为我与他人相比的行为辩解，按照严格的礼仪或公众舆论的标准，我是错的。我当时就像现在一样清楚地知道这一点。但他做了什么？我们不知道。好吧，他戒了酒。他努力戒赌。好吧，他没戒掉。是的。而且我们知道他确实有拈花惹草的嗜好。
He's had a massive row with his wife libby we can tell that from their letters because he sent her what letters saying um his eyes are blinded with tears he's very sorry he's let himself down yeah he's done something we don't know what it is i will not pretend to justify my conduct with others measured by the strict laws of propriety or public opinion i was was wrong. I know it then as plainly as I know it now. But what had he done? We don't know. Well, he's given up alcohol. He struggles to give up gambling. Well, he doesn't give it up. Yeah. And we know that he does have a taste for womanizing.
他确实有。他确实有。所以我猜很可能是那个。我也这么认为。我觉得绝对是那个。我能问你一下吗，回到第一集，无论那是什么时候，2023年还是什么的。我们现在是第几集？第47集。他的父亲，那个留胡子的。是的。
He does. He does indeed. So I would guess it's probably that. I think so too. I think it's absolutely that. Could I just ask you, so way back in episode one, whenever that was, 2023 or whatever. What episode are we now? Episode 47. His father, the one with the beard. Yeah.
他非常信奉上帝和忏悔之类的东西。是的。卡斯特的灵魂状态如何？他虔诚吗？他相信忏悔吗？真的很难说。他的父亲确实在他一生中不断给他写信。他收到家人的信，谈论内疚，谈论改善你的行为，
He's very into God and repentance and all of that. Yes. What is the state of Custer's soul? Is he devout? Does he believe in repentance? Really hard to tell. His father does write to him throughout his life letters. He gets letters from his family talking about guilt, talking about improving your behavior,
这类事情。我不认为我们能从卡斯特身上感受到他是一个，怎么说呢，精神动物。宗教人士。在传记中，或者实际上在信件中，都没有那种特别的宗教感。我的意思是，《我在平原上的生活》里也没有。不。我不认为他是反宗教的，或者说，明显是不信教的。
this kind of thing. I don't think we get much of a sense of Custer as a sort of, as it were, a spiritual animal. Religious man. There's no sense of that coming through in the biographies or indeed in the letters of a particular religiosity. I mean, there's nothing in Life of the Plains either. No. I don't think it's anti-religious or, as it were, markedly irreligious.
我认为这实际上并没有在他的精神生活中占据很大比重。但我确实认为他真诚地感到自己有标准，但他始终未能达到，就像我们所有人一样。我的意思是，他意识到自己在赌博方面让自己失望了，但他就是无法停止。他本能地是个赌徒。这就是他作战的方式，不是吗？他发动骑兵冲锋。
I think it just doesn't massively feature in his intellectual life, actually. But I do think he genuinely feels he has standards that he has failed consistently to live up to, as we all do. I mean, he's conscious of having sort of let himself down with the gambling stuff, but he just can't stop himself. He's a gambler by instinct. It's the way he campaigns, isn't it? He launches cavalry charges.
嗯，而且就他的妻子而言，拈花惹草是最糟糕的。因为他确实爱他的妻子，不是吗？是的，完全是。我的意思是，他们非常、非常亲密。他们非常忠诚。是的。所以那是最大的背叛。我的意思是，他确实爱她。
Well, and the womanizing is, in terms of his wife, the worst. Because he does love his wife, doesn't he? Yeah, totally. I mean, they're very, very close. They're very devoted. Yes. So that's the worst betrayal. I mean, he does love her.
我绝对这么认为。所以无论如何，她原谅了他。1870年，他们被派往堪萨斯州的海斯市（Hayes City），那里的警长是“野牛比尔”希科克（Wild Bill Hickok）。这太棒了。这些与让狂野西部变得传奇的一切事物的交汇点。正是如此。但实际上，汤姆，奇怪的是，我们认为卡斯特是边疆人、西部人，但他并不真的想待在那里。在梦里，他想回到纽约。所以1871年，当他获得长期休假时，他回到了纽约。他在落基山脉投资了一座银矿。
I think absolutely. So anyway, she forgives him. 1870, they're posted to Kansas, Hayes City, Kansas, where the sheriff is Wild Bill Hickok. It's so great. These kind of intersection points with everything that makes the Wild West kind of legendary. Exactly. But actually, the weird thing you see, Tom, is that we think about Custer as being a man of the frontier, a man of the West, but he doesn't really want to be there. In his dreams, he wants to be back in New York. So in 1871, when he gets a long period of leave, he goes back to New York. He invests in a silver mine in the Rockies.
所以这就是那个预言家所说的。你会进入采矿业。是的。采矿和铁路，这是预言家在27集前说的两件事，它们是1860年代和1870年代巨大的繁荣产业，卡斯特参与其中完全合情合理。这相当于你知道在1990年代投资互联网泡沫之类的，是的，这就是卡斯特在做的，而且他做得非常糟糕。你让我感到惊讶，所以他花了很多时间在
So this is what the clairvoyant had said. You'll get into mining. Yeah. And mining and railroads, which are the two things the clairvoyant had said 27 episodes ago, they are great boom industries in the 1860s and 1870s it makes total sense for Custer to get in on this it's the equivalent of you know in the 1990s or something investing in the dot-com boom yeah that's what Custer is doing and he does it very badly you amaze me so he spends lots of time kind of in
纽约闲逛，试图与财阀之类的人交朋友，因为那是他真正想要的世界，而不是平原的世界。他做了疯狂、鲁莽的投资吗？我想他此时确实做了糟糕的投资。所以他的银矿，我们真的不知道他为什么或如何参与其中。他的商业伙伴是来自密歇根的一个人，来自密歇根步兵团，像卡斯特一样在内战中服役过。但他有一种不安分。他从来没有为矿山筹集到足够的钱。人们会和他共进午餐，因为他是内战英雄，但他们说可能投资的钱却从未真正到位。所以1871年底，他还在军队里，然后被派往肯塔基州。
New York hanging around, trying to make friends with plutocrats and stuff, because that's the world he really wants, not the world of the planes. Does he make mad, rash investments? I think he does make bad investments at this point. So his silver mine, we don't really know why or how he got involved with it. His business partner is a guy from Michigan, from the Michigan infantry, who'd served in the Civil War, as Custer had. But there's a kind of restlessness to him. He never gets enough money for the mine. People will have lunch with him because he's a Civil War hero, but then the money that they said they might invest never quite materializes. So at the end of 1871, he's still in the army and he's then posted to Kentucky.
这是一个很好的例子，说明了……我知道你觉得政治不像我那样令人兴奋，汤姆，但重建时期的政治在卡斯特的故事中真的很重要。肯塔基州在内战中保持中立。它有很多奴隶。所以大约五分之一的人口是奴隶。它的一部分曾被南方邦联占领。战争结束时，肯塔基州发生了可怕的游击战，它有非常、非常庞大的准军事组织三K党（Ku Klux Klan）人口，这基本上就是卡斯特被派去镇压的对象。而卡斯特在这个问题上非常、非常软弱。
And this is a good example of how the, I know you don't find the politics as exciting as I do, Tom, but the sort of politics of reconstruction is really important in Custer's story. Kentucky had been neutral in the civil war. It had a lot of slaves. So about a fifth of the population was slaves. Part of it had been occupied by the Confederates. At the end of the war, there's terrible kind of guerrilla warfare in Kentucky, and it has a very, very large paramilitary Ku Klux Klan population, and that's basically what Custer has been sent to repress. And Custer is very, very weak on this issue.
所以他和利比实际上记得他的父亲非常种族主义。卡斯特是个民主党人，所以他并不真正相信华盛顿政府会积极干预，拆除南方或边境州白人至上主义的制度。实际上他们所做的是，他们花了很多时间与肯塔基州支持三K党的人，或者实际上是三K党成员的人混在一起，他并没有真正采取任何行动。你引用他的话，听起来非常像《乱世佳人》（Gone with the Wind），女人们像男人们一样迷人美丽，而男人们则像传说中那样富有骑士精神。
So he and Libby actually remember that his father is very racist. Custer has a Democrat, so he doesn't really believe in a kind of interventionist Washington government actively demolishing the institutions of kind of white supremacy in the South or in the border states. And actually what they do is they spend a lot of their time hanging out with people in Kentucky who are supportive of the Klan, or indeed members of the Klan, and he doesn't really lift a finger. You quote him, sounding very, very gone with the wind, the women are as charmingly beautiful as the men are proverbially chivalrous.
是的，他完全接受了这一点。记得在西点军校时，他有所有那些南方朋友，而且他非常同情南方吗？关于这一点，重要的一点是，这使他在一场争论中站在了错误的一边，而他的大赞助人谢里登将军（General Sheridan）和美国总统尤利西斯·S·格兰特（Ulysses S. Grant）则站在对立面。所以这再次扩大了他与格兰特之间的政治裂痕。我的意思是，奇怪的是，他当时一定真的相信这一点。完全相信。
Yeah, he totally buys into that. Remember at West Point he had all those Southern friends and he was very sympathetic to the South? And the important thing about that is that puts him on the wrong side of an argument in which General Sheridan, his great patron, and Ulysses S. Grant, the President of the United States, they are on the opposite side. So that, again, sort of widens the political breach between him and in particular with Grant. I mean, the weird thing is, he must really believe it then. Totally believes it.
为了愿意牺牲他的……我的意思是，损害他的职业生涯。是的，完全是。他相信这一点。我认为有趣的是，正如TJ·斯泰尔斯（TJ Styles）所说，他绝对有选择，但他选择了对他政治上最不利的选项，这表明，你知道，老爸的影响力还在。老爸的影响力挥之不去，并在他身上留下了真正的印记。公平地说，这并不全是种族主义。他出去了，谢里登有一天把他拉出去，去见俄罗斯的亚历克西斯大公（Grand Duke Alexis），还有“野牛比尔”（Buffalo Bill）。所以“野牛比尔”将在最后回到故事中。是的，他会。我实际上……这是我在这个时期对大平原最感兴趣的方面之一，我想，作为一个欧洲人，
To be willing to sacrifice his, I mean, compromise his career. Yeah, totally. He believes it. I think that's the interesting thing that as TJ Styles says, he absolutely had a choice and he chooses the option that is least politically advantageous for him, which is a sign that, you know, daddy has had his influence. Daddy's influence lingers and has left a real mark on him. It's not all racism, to be fair. He goes out, Sheridan drags him out one day to go and meet the Grand Duke Alexis of Russia, along with Buffalo Bill. So Buffalo Bill will be returning to the story at the very end. Yeah, he will. I actually, so this is one of the aspects of the Great Plains in this period I find most interesting, I guess, being European myself,
欧洲人即使在印第安战争发生时也走出去的方式。贵族们有点像出去打猎。有一个法国人，不是吗，在1880年代，他出去建造了一座卢瓦尔河城堡。哦，没错。是的。确实有。就在中间。他叫什么名字？北达科他州的德莫雷侯爵（Marquis de Moray）。我的意思是，真是太奇怪了。我想那个伊顿公学的家伙不是去进行大旅行，我的意思是，他实际上是加入了第7骑兵团，最后像圣塞巴斯蒂安一样被插满了箭。但我认为，存在暴力威胁，正如他们所认为的那样，异国情调的暴力是吸引力的一部分，
the way in which Europeans are going out, even as the Indian wars are happening. Aristocrats are kind of going out and going on hunting. And there's a French guy, isn't there, in the 1880s, who goes out and kind of builds a Loire chateau. Oh, that's right. Yes. Yeah, there is. Right in the middle. What's his name? The Marquis de Moray in North Dakota. I mean, just kind of really odd. And I suppose that Etonian guy who isn't going on a grand tour, I mean, he's actually enlisting with the 7th Cavalry and he ends up kind of feathered like St. Sebastian. But I suppose the fact that there is the threat of violence and as they would see it, exotic violence is a part of the appeal
完全是，是的，它吸引了欧洲文化中那种原始的“阿拉伯的劳伦斯”式的倾向，不是吗？这是一个人们会认为世界正变得越来越标准化、同质化等等的世界。我们谈到的《所罗门王的宝藏》（Solomon's Mines）里的莱德·哈格德（Rider Haggard）是什么？是的。他是个平原人。是的。饱经风霜。大型猎物。是的，大型猎物猎人。
totally is yeah it appeals to the kind of proto lawrence of arabia strain in sort of european culture doesn't it that this is a world of people would perceive the world as becoming increasingly standardized homogenized and so on what's the rider ha Haggard thing that we talked about in the Solomon's Mines. Yeah. He was a man of the plains. Yes. Weather beaten. Big game. Yeah, a big game hunter.
正是如此，所有这类东西。是的。所以无论如何，利比真正想要的是让他成为一颗文学巨星。你从《我在平原上的生活》中读到的那些东西，
Exactly. All of that kind of stuff. Yeah. So anyway, what Libby really wants is for him to be a big literary star. And that stuff that you read from My Love from the Plains,
他开始在这一点上写那些文章。卡斯特不是……很容易把他描绘成那种鲁莽、粗鲁的小丑。我认为这完全是错误的。他真的对很多事情感兴趣，他喜欢，像你一样汤姆，他喜欢化石，对化石着迷，收集化石。你说话时脸上的冷笑。不，不。
he started writing those articles about this point. Custer is not, it's very easy to paint him as this kind of reckless, boorish clown. And I think that's completely wrong. He's really interested in lots of, he loves, like you Tom, he loves fossils, mad on fossils, collects fossils. The sneer on your face as you say that. No, no.
嘴唇的卷曲。什么？那不是嘴唇卷曲。是吗？不。那是全心全意地分享我的热情。什么？那不是嘴唇卷曲。是吗？不。那是全心全意地分享我的热情。那是一种充满爱意和尊重的眼神，汤姆。哦，我太感动了。
Curling of the lip. What? That wasn't a curling lip. Was it? No. That was wholehearted sharing in my enthusiasm. What? That wasn't a curling lip. Was it? No. That was wholehearted sharing in my enthusiasm. That was a look of affection and respect. That's what that was, Tom. Oh, I'm so touched.
你提到了达尔文。卡斯特对所有这些想法都很感兴趣。他对科学和自然历史很感兴趣。当他写到美洲原住民、印第安人、拉科塔人（Lakota），随你怎么称呼他们时，他真的在他的著作中深入探讨了这一点，他说他们并不比人类低等。嗯，我的意思是，他们是以色列十个部落的后裔。我们已经提到过这一点了。是的。他真的对那个想法很感兴趣。
You mentioned Darwin. Custer is interested in all those ideas. He's interested in science and natural history. And when he writes about the Native Americans, the Indians, the Lakota, call them what you will, he really goes into this in his writings and he says they're not less than human. Well, I mean, they're the descendants of the 10 tribes of Israel. We've already mentioned that. Yeah. He's really interested in that idea.
而且他感兴趣的是，我们如何对待平原上无畏的骑兵战士？他将他对我认为他确实对这些人感兴趣和尊重的态度，与他认为他们必须被扫地出门的信念调和起来的方式是，他说他们永远无法被文明化。自然注定印第安人处于野蛮状态。他灵魂的每一个本能、每一个冲动都倾向于此。他不能既是他自己又被文明化。他必须消亡。卡斯特真的，我想他真的相信这一点。那不仅仅是一块遮羞布。他认为这是自然和科学的法则，这是平原印第安人的命运。继续。
And he's interested in how do we deal with the fearless horsemen warriors of the plains? The way he sort of reconciles his genuine, I think, interest and respect sort of in and for these people with his belief that they do have to be swept aside is that he says they can never be civilized. Nature intended the Indian for a savage state. Every instinct, every impulse of his soul inclines him to it. He cannot be himself and be civilized. He must fade away and die. Custer really, I think he really believes that. That's not just a fig leaf. He thinks this is the law of nature and of science, that this is the fate of the Plains Indians. Go on.
我的意思是，我想知道，也许我夸大了，因为我对这个主题感兴趣，但西部所有这些领土都充满了非凡的化石、恐龙、巨型哺乳动物等等，它们堆积在沉积层中，这样你就可以看到生命的层次，生存的周期已经兴起和衰落，它印在岩石、山丘、地面上，第7骑兵团正在漫游，科学家和古生物学家正在这一时期将其带入光明，这是否在投射一种想法，即人类文明遵循同样的路线，正如恐龙被哺乳动物取代一样，所以印第安人，正如卡斯特所说，必须被白人取代。
I mean, I wonder, maybe I'm overemphasizing it because I am interested in the subject, but whether the discovery that all of these territories in the West are full of extraordinary fossils, dinosaurs, giant mammals, whatever, and they're stacked in layers of sediment so that you can see the layers of life, that cycles of existence have risen and fallen, and it's stamped in the rocks, in the hills, in the ground that the 7th Cavalry are roaming, and that scientists and paleontologists are bringing it to light in this very period, is casting the idea that human civilizations follow the same route, that just as dinosaurs have been superseded by mammals, so Indians, as Custer would put it, must be superseded by the white man.
汤姆，我不认为这太异想天开。我认为，很明显，卡斯特是他那个时代的人。他阅读广泛。人们在谈论所有这些想法。他们在谈论达尔文的理论。甚至当他们没有自觉地谈论它们时，语言，正如我们从卡斯特自己的著作中所知，那种达尔文主义的语言渗透到了谈话中。他写到印第安人的方式，在一点上他说，
I don't think that's too fanciful at all, Tom. I think, clearly, Custer is a man of his age. He reads widely. People are talking about all of these ideas. They're talking about Darwin's theories. And it's not even when they're consciously talking about them, but the language, as we know from Custer's own writings, the kind of Darwinist language permeates into sort of conversation. And the way he writes about the Indians, at one point he says,
他们不是动物，他们是像我们一样的人类，但他们就像一个基本上被自然法则等注定要灭亡的物种。我认为，正如你所说，它发生在这个有着层层深厚历史的景观中，是的，显然我认为一定有一些间接的心理联系。我的意思是，这也是因为美洲原住民自己对化石非常熟悉，并讲述了关于它们的各种故事，比如雷鸟（thunderbirds）的故事等等。现在古生物学家带着凿子出来说，实际上，你知道，这是来自侏罗纪时期什么的。
they're not animals, they're humans like us, but they are like a species that is basically doomed by the laws of nature and whatnot. I think that, as you say, the fact that it's taking place in this landscape with layers upon layers of deep, deep history, yeah, obviously I think there must be some indirect psychological link. I mean, it's also that the Native Americans themselves are very familiar with fossils and tell all kinds of stories about them, say stories of thunderbirds and so on. And now that the paleontologists are coming out with their chisels and saying, actually, you know, this was from the Jurassic period or whatever.
是的。同样，它只是在磨练一个显然非常、非常有用的想法，你知道，对于军队和政府来说，军队是其中的前沿。对于定居者和铁路建设者以及各种各样的事情。嗯，铁路，我认为那是整个时间都在推进的东西。我的意思是，字面上的推进。他们正在建造更多的轨道。铁路正在通过。
Yeah. Again, it's just kind of sharpening an idea that is obviously very, very useful, you know, for the army and for the government that the army are the cutting edge of. And for settlers and railroad builders and all kinds of things. Well, railroads, I think that's the thing that's advancing the whole time. I mean, literally advancing. They're building more track. The railroads are coming through.
所以1873年春天，卡斯特最终来到了达科他领地（Dakota Territory），一个叫亚伯拉罕·林肯堡（Fort Abraham Lincoln）的地方，在密苏里河上，与俾斯麦（Bismarck）镇相对。这些都是重要的地方。再次重申，达科他，我的意思是，它只是拉科塔的另一种发音。是的。在这里，卡斯特，在其他士兵的所有描述中他实际上相当痛苦，因为他讨厌成为一名写字台将军。他讨厌所有这些，而且他很不擅长。
So in the spring of 1873, Custer ends up in the Dakota Territory, a place called Fort Abraham Lincoln on the Missouri River opposite the town of Bismarck. These are important places. And just to reiterate, Dakota is, I mean, it's just another pronunciation of Lakota. Yeah. And here, Custer, who's actually pretty miserable in all the accounts of him from other soldiers, because he hates kind of being a pen-pushing general. He hates all that and he's very bad at it.
但他获得了一点行动的机会，因为北太平洋铁路（Northern Pacific Railway）计划通过这片领土。现在，北太平洋铁路是反对平原印第安人的现代性的完美象征，因为它是美国第一个真正的大投资银行家，一个叫杰伊·库克（Jay Cook）的人的项目，他基本上资助了内战中的联邦战争努力，即北方。他是目前为止美国最知名的金融家。这是他的铁路，计划是直接穿过拉科塔领地。现在，每个人都知道这意味着野牛的死亡。是的。铁路带来了定居者，他们带来了从窗户探出身子向野牛射击的人，所以从1872年到1874年，是的，仅在南部平原的非印第安猎人就杀死了超过三百万头野牛，到1870年代中期，野牛在中部平原几乎灭绝。是的，所以这使得拉科塔人所在的地区成为最后的据点。每个人都很清楚他们不会存在太久了。
But he gets a chance for a bit of action because the Northern Pacific Railway is planning to come through this territory. Now, the Northern Pacific is the perfect symbol of the modernity against which people set the Plains Indians, because it is the project of America's first really big investment banker, a guy called Jay Cook, who had basically bankrolled the Union war effort, the North, in the Civil War. He is by far the best known, at this point, financier in America. It's his railroad, and the plan is for it to go right through the Lakota territory. Now, everybody knows that this means death to the Bison. Yeah. That railroads bring settlers, they bring people leaning out of the windows taking pot shots at bison so from 1872 to 1874 yeah non-indian hunters on the southern plains alone killed more than three million bison by the mid-1870s bison were nearly extinct on the central plains yeah and so that leaves the region where the lakota are as its last holdout. And it's obvious to everyone that they're not going to be around for long.
所以首先，每个人都知道并想要，他们想要野牛被消灭。所以谢里登将军、谢尔曼将军（General Sherman），在他们的通信中，他们一次又一次地说，我们开始吧，让他们杀戮和剥皮，直到水牛被消灭。而那个词“消灭”（exterminated），对我们来说有如此可怕的含义，他们经常使用它。不仅是在谈论野牛，而且是在谈论平原印第安人。他们将两者等同起来。所以谢尔曼说，白人公众强烈要求消灭，这说起来容易做起来难。但他确实说，我们不会被单纯的人类情感所动摇。现在，他接着说，我非常乐意消灭那些派出偷窃、
So first of all, everybody knows and wants, they want the bison to be exterminated. So General Sheridan, General Sherman, in their correspondence, they say again and again, here we go, let them kill and skin until the buffalo are exterminated. And that word exterminated, which to us has such terrifying connotations, they use that a lot. Not talking not just of the bison, but of the Plains Indians. They equate the two. So Sherman, the white public are clamorous for extermination, which is easier said than done. But he says, we're not moved by mere human sentiments. Now, he then goes on to say, I'm very happy to exterminate Indians who send out thieving,
谋杀团伙的印第安人，但我不会批准消灭那些只是安静、听话的印第安人。他真是太慷慨了。这真是太好了，不是吗？但我认为他们有，正如卡斯特所做的那样，一种假设，即实际上消灭是自然的终点，而他们所做的是他们只是在尽可能人道地平滑这个过程。这就是他们思考它的方式。这非常令人不寒而栗，因为当然，这种消灭整个
murdering parties, but I would not sanction the extermination of Indians who are just quiet and do what they're told. That's big of him. That's so kind, isn't it? But I think they have, as Custer does, an assumption that actually extermination is the natural endpoint and that what they are doing is they are just smoothing that process, but as humanely as possible. That's how they think of it. It's very chilling because, of course, this scientific approach to eradicating entire
民族的科学方法将吹回欧洲。这种对种族灭绝的达尔文主义辩护正在蔓延到帝国地区，即正在被殖民的地区。但它们会回到欧洲，你知道，我们知道那里发生了什么。当然。我的意思是，将美国军队的计划与纳粹的计划等同起来公平吗？嗯，进行这种对话绝对是公平的。如果不这样做才奇怪，但我不认为将两者等同起来是公平的。所以如果谢尔曼或谢里登在这里，他们会说，听着，
peoples is going to blow back into Europe. This kind of Darwinian justification for, effectively, genocide is spreading out into the imperial regions, the areas that are being colonized. But they will go back to Europe, you know, and we know what happens there. Of course. I mean, is it fair to equate the plans of the US army to those of the Nazis? Well, it's definitely fair to have the conversation. It'd be weird not to, but I don't think it's fair to equate the two. So if Sherman or Sheridan were here, they would say, listen,
我们不相信大规模屠杀无辜人民。绝对不。但我们相信他们的生活方式必须消失。同化是他们想要的。同化。所以我们之前谈过这一点，他们的计划基本上不是一种种族灭绝运动。这是一种文化压制。我的意思是，本质上，梦想是美洲原住民成为美国人，就像意大利人、爱尔兰人或德国人正在成为美国人一样。正是如此。大熔炉，他们和所有人一起在熔炉中融合……现在当然，他们会说我们比我们之前的人更进步、更人道，因为他们对我们的意图很诚实，我们不是试图躲在你知道的条约之类的背后，我们确实打算打破，我们不打算打破我们的
we don't believe in wholesale slaughter of innocent people. Absolutely not. But we believe that their way of life has to go. Assimilation is what they want. Assimilation. So we talked about this before, that their plan basically is not a kind of racial campaign of eradication. It's a cultural suppression. And I mean, essentially the dream is that the Native American peoples become American in the way that Italians or Irish or Germans are becoming American. Exactly. The melting pot, that they're melted in the melting pot with everybody else um now of course they would say we are much more progressive and humane than the people who preceded us because they were honest about our intentions we're not trying to hide behind you know treaties and stuff that we do intend to break we don't intend to break our
协议。我们会给他们保留地，我们会给他们补给，我们会给他们教室和衣服之类的东西。还有农场。还有农场，他们将成为美国人。他们会说，听着，这是一种和平政策。这不是一种战争政策。这不是一种让矿工和定居者挑选他们的政策。我们想要规范它，系统化它，与他们达成我们坚持的协议，他们的生活方式将会消失，
deals we'll give them the reservations we to break our deals. We'll give them the reservations, we'll give them supplies, and we'll give them school rooms and clothes and stuff. And farms. And farms, and they will become Americans. And they would say, listen, this is a peace policy. This is not a war policy. It's not a policy of letting miners and settlers pick them off. We want to regularize it, systematize it, do a deal with them that we stick to, and their way of life will disappear,
但这就是自然法则。你知道，这就是他们会说的。现在，你知道，我们在21世纪，很容易去评判这一点并说，哦，好吧，这有可怕的、有害的后果以及所有这类事情。当然，另一件事是，我们知道平原印第安人并没有注定要灭绝。我的意思是，他们仍然存在。
but such is the law of nature. You know, that's what they would say. Now, you know, we in the 21st century, it's easy to kind of judge that and say, oh, well, this has terrible, baleful consequences and all this kind of thing. The other thing, of course, we know the Plains Indians were not doomed to extinction. I mean, they're still around.
实际上，有趣的是，尽管他们对文化差异、历史和科学等感兴趣，但他们极大地低估了那些民族认同的韧性，我会这么说。我的意思是，你可以说更多，即美洲原住民对1860年代和1870年代发生的事情的理解现在已经成为规范，实际上我们正在这次讨论中代表它。是的。汤姆，这会很有趣，我们许多美国听众可能已经在想这一点了，如果我们是美国人，我们会如何进行这种对话，对吧？我们会更有利害关系，
Actually, the funny thing is that for all their interest in kind of cultural differences and history and science and stuff, they massively underestimated the resilience of those ethnic identities, I would say. I mean, you could say more than that, that the Native American understanding of what happens in the 1860s and 1870s has now become normative, that effectively we are representing it in this discussion. Yeah. It'd be interesting, Tom, and lots of our American listeners may already be thinking this, it'd be interesting how we would have this conversation if we were American, right? We'd have more skin in the game,
正如他们所说。我们会参与其中。嗯，我相信当我们确实说英国人在南非时，我们会进行这类讨论。是的。是的。你知道，或者实际上在塔斯马尼亚。是的，当然。当然。好的。
as it were. We would have a stake in it. Well, I'm sure that we will be having these kinds of discussions when and if we do say the British in South Africa. Yeah. Yeah. You know, or indeed in Tasmania. Yeah, of course. Of course. Okay.
我们不能忽视叙事，汤姆。我们忽视了叙事。令人震惊的场景。不，不，不。所以他们派出了一个调查团，1871年。好的。没问题。然后他们在1872年派出了一个。
We can't lose sight of the narrative, Tom. We've lost sight of the narrative. Shocking scenes. No, no, no. So they send out a survey mission 1871. Fine. No problem. Then they send one out in 1872.
这实际上是坐牛和疯马真正走到一起的时刻，不是吗？因为他们之前没有大规模合作过，大规模的交叉，是的，这是一种超级英雄风格的团队合作，是的，他们联手恐吓调查队，用烟斗进行的精彩行动，不是吗？是的，伟大的烟斗行动，所以疯马骑着马挥舞着长矛，有点吓坏了测量员。然后坐牛，他只是拿着一个烟斗。他没有携带其他武器。他坐下来开始抽他的烟斗。
And this is actually the moment when sitting bull and crazy horse really come together isn't it because they haven't massively collaborated before now massive crossover yeah it's a sort of superhero style team up yeah they team up to intimidate the survey party brilliant action with a pipe isn't it yeah great pipe action so crazy horse rides around waving a lance and sort of terrifies the surveyors. And then Sitting Bull, he's just carrying a pipe. He's otherwise unarmed. He sits down and starts smoking his pipe.
美国士兵有点在向他射击，因为他在射程内。这充分说明了他们的训练和能力。他只是坐在那里抽着烟斗。他们错过了在他周围飞舞的子弹，但没有一颗击中他。嗯，我的意思是，让我们也说这充分说明了他的勇气，当然，你可能会说他的药物，是的，这是他的力量，子弹都错过了他，是的，所以美国人发现这非常、非常令人不安，实际上他们最终撤退了，他们放弃了，他们说我们不可能与这个拿着烟斗的家伙竞争，我的意思是，什么小伙子。所以当他们回来时，谢里登对此绝对愤怒。玩烟斗。
And the American soldiers are kind of shooting at him because he's within range. And it speaks volumes about their training and ability. That he's just sitting there smoking his pipe on the ground. And they're missing bullets flying around him, but none of them hit him. Well, I mean, let's also say it speaks volumes for his courage of course and you might say his medicine yeah it's his powers the bullets are all missing him yeah so the americans find this very very unsettling and actually they end up retreating they give up they say there's no way we can compete with this fellow with this pipe i mean what lad. So when they get back, Sheridan is absolutely livid at this. Play with a pipe.
我打败了邦联。你到底在做什么？这简直是垃圾。所以他派了另一支远征队。这就是卡斯特获得机会的地方。这是1873年。卡斯特穿着那套行头。他现在有了每一个随后的出场习惯
I beat the Confederacy. What the hell are you doing? This is rubbish. So he sends another expedition. This is where Custer gets his chance. This is 1873. And Custer dresses the part. He's now got the habit of every subsequent appearance
他将在这个播客中出现。他穿着一套荒谬的鹿皮套装，一顶巨大的帽子。而且他的头发此时又长了，不是吗？他的头发很长，正是如此。所以印第安人叫他“长发”（Long Hair）。他们确实这么叫。他带着测量员出发了。团队中有一个科学部分。
he'll make in this podcast. He's wearing a ludic of every subsequent appearance he'll make in this podcast. He's wearing a ludicrous kind of buckskin suit, a huge hat. And his hair is long again at this point, isn't it? His hair is long, exactly. So the Indians call him Long Hair. They do. And he sets off with the surveyors. There's a scientific part of the team.
有第7骑兵团。他喜欢这个。他去寻找化石。这就像《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander）小说中的马图林（Maturin）。他有成箱成箱的东西。我的意思是，他是一个充满热情的人。他是。我真正喜欢卡斯特的一点是，他拥抱机会。我认为这样说是公平的。有机会去打猎或寻找化石什么的。他会抓住它。
There's the 7th Cavalry. He loves this. He goes hunting for fossils. It's like kind of Maturin in the Master and Commander novels. He's got boxes and boxes of stuff. I mean, he's a man of enthusiasm. He is. And the thing I really like about Custer is that he embraces opportunity. I think it's fair to say. There's a chance to go hunting or looking for fossils or whatever. He'll take it.
冲锋、战斗，无论什么。他是一个充满热情的人。是的，完全是。他现在新的大热情，在《历史的余味》中不时出现的东西，是动物标本剥制术。这是他真正进入动物标本剥制术的时候。我的意思是，我们谈到了他有多喜欢动物，他非常喜欢它们，以至于他想把它们填充起来。所以雅科·马卡科（Jaco Macaco），《历史的余味》的一位好朋友，最终被填充了，威斯敏斯特坑（Westminster Pit）的战斗猴子。我们上次谈到，我想，或者几个播客前，关于你想要填充伊恩·博瑟姆（Ian Botham）的愿望。
Charging, fighting, whatever. He's a man of enthusiasm. Yeah, totally. And his big new enthusiasm now, something that occurs from time to time on the rest of his history is taxidermy. This is when he really gets into taxidermy. I mean, we've talked about how he loves animals and he loves them so much that he wants to stuff them. So Jaco Macaco, a great friend of the rest of his history, ended up being stuffed, the fighting monkey of the Westminster Pit. And we talked last time, I think, or a couple of podcasts ago, about your desire to stuff Ian Botham.
我怀疑这是有史以来第一个关于卡斯特和小大角战役的播客系列。它以填充英国伟大的板球全能选手伊恩·博瑟姆的想法为特色。是的，那是真的。我不记得我们是怎么谈到那个的了。所以无论如何，卡斯特使用了一个非规定的烹饪炉，这让他陷入了巨大的麻烦，与那个
I suspect this is the first podcast series that's ever been done on Custer and the Little Big Horn. It featured the idea of stuffing England's great cricketing all-rounder, Ian Botham. Yeah, that's true. I can't quite remember how we got onto that. So anyway, Custer uses a non-regulation cooking stove that gets him into massive trouble with the guy
实际上指挥远征的人，叫斯坦利（Stanley）。所以卡斯特被那个负责远征的人看得很低，实际上为了惩罚他使用错误的炉子，把他送到了纵队的后面，汤姆，疯狂的场景，但随后卡斯特完全救赎了自己，他已经和这个叫“血刀”（Bloody Knife）的侦察兵变得亲密了，他是一个了不起的角色，我的意思是，他本身就值得一个播客系列，是的，他有一个洪克帕帕拉科塔（Hunkpapa Lakota）父亲和一个阿里卡拉（Arikara）母亲。所以是一个不同的群体。所以这非常像19世纪的寄宿学校故事。因为他被拉科塔人欺负。
who's actually commanding the expedition, who's called Stanley. So Custer's held a very low regard by the guy running the expedition and actually sends him to the back of the column as a punishment tom for using the wrong stove crazy scenes but then custer completely redeems himself he has become pally with this scout called bloody knife he's a tremendous character i mean he's worthy of a podcast series in himself yeah he had a a Hunkpapa Lakota father and an Arikara mother. So a different group. So this is very like 19th century boarding school stories. Because he's bullied by the Lakota.
因为他有来自不同部落群体的父母。是的。他不属于正确的房子。他被欺负。不，他不属于正确的房子，他被欺负，不，他不适合，他被极其恶劣地欺负，特别是被这个叫高尔（Gall）的家伙，拉科塔的弗莱什曼（Flashman），他将在小大角战役中扮演重要角色，他是拉科塔的弗莱什曼，他会在橄榄球队中非常突出，是的，他很吵，他有点，他一直在毯子里抛掷可怜的“血刀”，就像没人管一样。
Because he has people from different tribal groupings as parents. Yeah. He doesn't belong in the right house. He gets bullied. No, he doesn't belong in the right house he gets bullied no he doesn't fit him he gets hideously bullied especially by this guy called gall g-a-l-l the flashman of of the lakota who will have a big role to play in little bighorn he is the flashman of the lakota he would be very prominent in the rugby team yeah he's loud he's kind of he have been tossing poor Bloody Knife in a blanket like nobody's business.
是的。然而因为他们不在公立学校，他实际上做的是他剥了“血刀”兄弟的头皮并杀了他们。所以，是的，“血刀”，尽管他是半个拉科塔人，但他恨拉科塔人。是的。他以绝对的激情恨他们。他最终作为美国军队的侦察兵工作。他相当粗鲁，不是吗，当着卡斯特的面，他有点嘲笑他，说他不会射击，是的，卡斯特有点把他看作是一个小丑，就像那种宫廷弄臣
Yeah. Whereas because they're not in a public school, what he actually does is he scalps Bloody Knife's brothers and kills them. So, yeah, Bloody Knife, even though he's half Lakota, he hates the Lakota. Yeah. He hates them with an absolute passion. And he ends up working as a scout for the US Army. And he's quite rude, isn't he, to Custer's's face he kind of laughs at him and says that he can't shoot yeah and custer kind of sees him as a bit of a joker like the kind of the court jester that
那种东西，对吧，一个傻瓜，我本来想说就像他的傻瓜，不是吗，是的，无论如何，卡斯特通常喜欢侦察兵，他花了很多时间和他们在一起，他总是和他们相处得很好，我认为这实际上反映了卡斯特的好处，他总是和侦察兵相处得很好，他花了很多时间和他们在一起，他总是和他们相处得很好，我认为这实际上反映了卡斯特的好处，他总是和侦察兵相处得很好，所以八月初，“血刀”对卡斯特说，我想我们被跟踪了，你知道，我看到了一些迹象，我不知道侦察兵看到了什么，但无论如何，他看到了它们，踪迹，我想踪迹和人们准备伏击我们，8月4日早些时候，这正是发生的事情。拉科塔人，他们试图做一个费特曼大屠杀（Fetterman massacre）机动来引诱卡斯特出来。长话短说，实际发生的是卡斯特和他的手下，大约90人，最终被三倍于他们的拉科塔人困住了
kind of thing right a fool i was going to say like he's like his fool isn't he yeah anyway custer loves scouts generally he spends loads of time with him he always gets on really well with them i think it reflects well on custer actually that he always gets on well with the scouts generally he spends loads of time with them he always gets on really well with them i think it reflects well on custer actually that he always gets on well with the scouts so in the early days of august bloody knife says to custer i think we're being followed you know i've seen kind of signs i don't know what a scout sees but anyway he's seen them trails i think trails and people preparing to ambush us and early on the 4th of august this is exactly what happens. The Lakota, they try to do a Fetterman massacre maneuver to lure Custer out. And to cut a sort of very long story short, what actually happens is that Custer and his men, and about 90 men, end up being trapped by three times as many Lakota
在黄石河边的这些树林里。拉科塔人和他们的夏延盟友有点骑马绕着他们。他们试图通过点燃草地把他们烧出来。而卡斯特，现在，我认为这很重要，因为我认为质疑卡斯特只是一个非常鲁莽的糟糕指挥官的想法真的很重要。他的本能总是做那种疯狂的、挥舞着剑的赌博。这有点像，不是吗？但在这里他根本没有那样做。他让他的手下待在一起。他把他们部署在防线上。
in these woods by the Yellowstone River. And there are Lakota and their Cheyenne allies kind of riding around them. They try and burn them out by setting fire to the grass. And Custer, now, I think this is important because it's really important, I think, to question the idea that Custer is just a terrible commander who's really reckless. His instinct is always to do the sort of mad swashbuckling gamble. It kind of is though, isn't it? But here he doesn't do that at all. He keeps his men together. He deploys them in a defensive line.
他保持秩序和纪律。他没有冲出去。他说，我们不会上当。他们试图引诱我们出来并困住我们。卡斯特在这里做得很好，汤姆，我想。但他的假设是第7骑兵团总是会打败美洲原住民。我的意思是，那是他的指导假设。而在事件中，这并不一定会被证明是真的，不是吗？
He keeps order and discipline. He doesn't charge out. He says, we won't fall for that. They're trying to lure us out and to trap us. Custer does really well here, Tom, I think. But his assumption is that the 7th Cavalry will always beat Native Americans. I mean, that's his guiding assumption. And in the event that is going to be shown not necessarily to be true, isn't it?
他保持秩序和纪律。他没有冲出去。他说，我们不会上当。他们试图引诱我们出去并困住我们。汤姆，我认为卡斯特在这里表现得非常好。但他假设第七骑兵团总是能打败美洲原住民。我的意思是，这是他的指导假设。而事实证明，这并不一定正确，不是吗？
Of course, yes. But the reason that he's charging out, he's happy to venture into places where he may well be ambushed, where there may well be giant villages. And he assumes that he will always have the beating of them. I think that reflects a certain degree of swashbuckling confidence that in the event will come to seem misplaced. I take your point that he's never frightened because he always thinks they'll win. But I think in this case, I think you're being a tiny bit harsh on Custer because I think it's the Lakota here that have attacked him, not vice versa.
当然，是的。但他之所以冲锋陷阵，是因为他乐于冒险进入那些很可能遭到伏击、很可能有大型村庄的地方。他认为自己总能打败他们。我认为这反映出一种某种程度上的鲁莽自信，这种自信最终会被证明是错位的。我明白你的意思，他从不害怕，因为他总认为他们会赢。但我认为在这种情况下，你对卡斯特有点太苛刻了，因为我认为是拉科塔人先攻击了他，而不是反过来。
Yeah, but I mean, he's kind of ridden into their territory. He has, but he's under orders he hasn't done it out of well fine but i mean that's no skin off the lakota nose no okay fair enough anyway he does do well you know he does really well dominic the other thing yeah is the weaponry i know that you love military hardware can't get enough of it the assumption that the americans have rifles and the ind Indians have bows and arrows. It's very hardwired, isn't it, into the popular mythology of it. It is.
是啊，但我的意思是，他算是闯入了他们的领地。确实如此，但他是在执行命令，他并不是出于……好吧，但这对拉科塔人来说没什么损失。好吧，有道理。总之，他确实做得很好，你知道，他表现得非常好。多米尼克，另一件事是，是的，就是武器装备。我知道你喜欢军事硬件，怎么看都不够。人们普遍认为美国人有步枪，而印第安人只有弓箭。这在流行神话中根深蒂固，不是吗？确实如此。
The Lakota actually have, I mean, they're pretty well armed as well. Yeah, they have rifles. The one problem the Lakota have is getting ammunition. Do you know who gave the Lakota their first rifles? Make you feel very patriotic. Oh. It was the British in 1811. Really?
拉科塔人实际上，我的意思是，他们也装备得相当好。是的，他们有步枪。拉科塔人面临的一个问题是获取弹药。你知道是谁给了拉科塔人第一批步枪吗？这会让你感到非常爱国。哦。是英国人在1811年给的。真的吗？
Yeah. For the War of 1812. Just before the outbreak of war. So it was us. Well, that's good behavior. Yeah. Oh, that's very pleasing. Yeah. And so Custer actually is often complaining about the fact that the state government is giving guns to the people that he's then having to go out and fight with. Well, of course. So if you take the offer of going to a reservation, what you want to get is you want supplies, you want blankets, you want food and all that. But what the Lakota are always asking the reservation agents and things for is they're saying, please can we have some guns?
是的。为了1812年战争。就在战争爆发前夕。所以是我们。嗯，那真是“好行为”。是啊。哦，那真是令人高兴。是的。所以卡斯特实际上经常抱怨州政府给那些他不得不去与之战斗的人提供枪支。嗯，当然。所以如果你接受去保留地的提议，你想要得到的是补给、毯子、食物等等。但拉科塔人总是向保留地代理人要求的是，他们说，请问我们能要些枪吗？
And that's a real source of contention, actually. They say we want the guns to hunt the bison. It's really important for us to be able to do it. But, of course, the Americans are often quite torn about this because why do we want to give them guns then they'll probably use them on us yeah so custer in my life on the plains i mean he he talks about the wise foresight and strong love of fair play which prevails in the indian department which seeing that its wars are determined to fight is equally determined that there shall be no advantage taken but that the two sides shall be armed alike yeah so very kind of heavy sarcasm there.
这实际上是一个真正的争论焦点。他们说我们想要枪是为了猎杀野牛。这对我们来说非常重要。但是，当然，美国人对此往往感到非常纠结，因为我们为什么要给他们枪呢？那样他们可能会用枪对付我们。是啊，所以卡斯特在《我在平原上的生活》中，我的意思是，他谈到了印第安事务局中盛行的“明智的远见和对公平竞争的热爱”，该局看到其战争决定要打，也同样决定不占任何优势，而是双方应武装对等。是啊，那里有非常沉重的讽刺意味。
He says the red man is not far behind his more civilized brother in the art of war. But I think there is an element of exaggeration there, isn't there? A little bit. I mean, the guns that the Americans have are better quality. By and large, often they just have single shot carbines, though. So it's not like they're going, there a big difference between the americans at this point and let us say if you think about the british in the sudan or something you know mowing people down with their machine guns this is absolutely not the case at this point on the western frontier i mean often custer's men their guns don't work they explode in their faces
他说红种人在战争艺术上并不落后于他那更文明的兄弟。但我认为其中有夸大的成分，不是吗？有一点。我的意思是，美国人拥有的枪支质量更好。不过总的来说，他们通常只有单发卡宾枪。所以这不像他们……在这一点上，美国人和我们说，如果你想到苏丹的英国人或其他什么人，你知道，用机枪扫射人们，这在西部边境的这一点上绝对不是这样。我的意思是，卡斯特手下的人，他们的枪往往不好用，会在他们脸上爆炸。
the men themselves are terribly badly trained and don't know what they're doing. All of which makes it weird. And I guess expressive of the sense of dash and self-confidence that makes Custer such an effective performer up until he no longer is. Yeah. That he can kind of ride into battle and get his men to believe that they can do this. Yeah. Because he does it again a few days later the
士兵们自己训练极其糟糕，根本不知道自己在做什么。所有这些都让人觉得很奇怪。我想这表达了一种冲劲和自信，使卡斯特成为一个有效的表演者，直到他不再是为止。是啊。他可以冲进战场，让他的手下相信他们能做到这一点。是啊。因为几天后他又做了一次。
11th of august there's a lakota attack again custer's men are cornered on the banks of the yellowstone sitting bull is watching this by the way from the bluffs across the river so although custer and sitting bull never actually as it were meet this is the first time i guess that they've been if you're making film it's the first time they're in the same shot yeah sitting bull sees long hair exactly and the Lakota are taunting Custer's men come out come out we're gonna have those horses of yours at some stage you may as well cross and and like have the fight and give them to us now and Custer again Tom I think does well he says no no hold on hold on, hold on. Let's buy that time.
8月11日，拉科塔人再次发动攻击，卡斯特的人被困在黄石河岸边。顺便说一句，坐牛正从河对岸的悬崖上看着这一切。所以虽然卡斯特和坐牛实际上从未见过面，我想这是他们第一次，如果你在拍电影的话，这是他们第一次出现在同一个镜头里。是啊，坐牛看到了“长发”。正是如此，拉科塔人在嘲讽卡斯特的人：“出来，出来，我们迟早会得到你们的那些马，你们不如过河来打一仗，现在就把它们给我们。”卡斯特又一次，汤姆，我认为他做得很好，他说：“不，不，等等，等等，等等。让我们争取时间。”
Don't do anything rash. All of this kind of thing. And then finally a relief force arrives under Stanley, the guy commanding the expedition who by now actually has totally changed his mind about Custer and thinks that Custer is a great fellow. And then Custer makes a great Helms deep charge. Yeah. He forms a line.
不要做任何鲁莽的事。所有这些事情。然后最后，在斯坦利指挥下的一支救援部队到达了，他是指挥这次远征的人，他现在实际上已经完全改变了对卡斯特的看法，认为卡斯特是个了不起的家伙。然后卡斯特进行了一次伟大的“圣盔谷”式冲锋。是啊。他排成了一列。
His hair is flying. They strike up this tune, Gary Owen, this Irish jig they like to do, and they all charge out. And it's very dramatic. The thing about Custer's charge is, as we said in the very first episode, he knows when to do it, but he does love a charge. He does indeed. It works very well.
他的头发在飞扬。他们奏响了这首曲子，《加里·欧文》，他们喜欢跳的那种爱尔兰吉格舞曲，然后他们全都冲了出去。这非常戏剧性。关于卡斯特的冲锋，正如我们在第一集里所说，他知道什么时候该冲锋，但他确实喜欢冲锋。他确实如此。这非常有效。
The Lakota run away. Everybody says Custer has redeemed himself. The expedition has been a success, a relative success. Sheridan writes to him and says, well done. Brilliant. Everyone thinks you're great. The newspapers say, America's glorious boy is back. And Custer celebrates, Tom. You've seen this? He celebrates by writing a letter to his wife about his penis of course he does john has been making john yeah john has uh been making constant and earnest inquiries for his bunkie for a long time and this morning he seems more persistent than ever probably due to the fact that he knows
拉科塔人逃跑了。每个人都说卡斯特救赎了自己。这次远征取得了成功，相对的成功。谢里丹写信给他，说做得好。太棒了。每个人都认为你很伟大。报纸说，美国的荣耀之子回来了。卡斯特庆祝了，汤姆。你看到了吗？他通过写信给他的妻子谈论他的阴茎来庆祝。当然他会这么做。约翰一直在为他的铺位伙伴做持续而热切的询问，已经很长时间了，今天早上他似乎比以往任何时候都更坚持，这可能是因为他知道
he is homeward bound and And homeward bound he is. All right. So on that rather underwhelming note, Tom, I think we should take a break. We will return after the break. There'll be no more such talk because Gusta is going to the Black Hills. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他要回家了。而他确实要回家了。好吧，带着那个相当令人失望的音符，汤姆，我想我们应该休息一下。休息后我们会回来。不会再有这样的谈话了，因为卡斯特要去黑山了。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Custer has done very, very well on the Yellowstone expedition, redeemed himself, he's a hero again. And now, Dominic, we're in 1873. Yeah.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com，也就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。卡斯特在黄石远征中做得非常、非常好，救赎了自己，他又成了英雄。现在，多米尼克，我们是在1873年。是啊。
A chance is approaching for him to have another crack. There is. There is another chance. So just to give people a bit of context on this, the big thing that 1873 is well known for in American history is a tremendous stock market crash. So it's called the Panic of 1873. People used to call this, by the way, the Great Depression. Yeah.
他有另一个机会再试一次。确实有。还有另一个机会。所以为了给人们一点背景，1873年在美国历史上最著名的大事是一场巨大的股市崩盘。所以它被称为1873年恐慌。顺便说一句，人们过去常称之为“大萧条”。是啊。
Before the Great Depression happened. And it's railroads that crash, including Northern Pacific. And it's the empire of this guy, Jay Cook, who we talked about in the first half, who was the great kind of railroad banker and railroad financier. The impact of this crash is absolutely seismic. It's completely forgotten now because nobody studies the history of the 1870s and 1880s, really. But, you know, to give you an example, a quarter of all the people in New York City lost their jobs in the next few months after this crash in September 1873. And why this matters is it puts enormous pressure on the frontier, because it means that there are a lot of people whose lives in the big cities of the East Coast have been destroyed
在大萧条发生之前。是铁路公司崩盘了，包括北太平洋铁路。这是我们在前半部分谈到的那个家伙杰·库克的帝国，他是伟大的铁路银行家和铁路金融家。这次崩盘的影响是绝对地震级的。现在它被完全遗忘了，因为没有人真正研究1870年代和1880年代的历史。但是，你知道，给你举个例子，在1873年9月这次崩盘后的几个月里，纽约市四分之一的人失去了工作。这之所以重要，是因为它给边境带来了巨大的压力，因为这意味着有很多人在东海岸大城市的生活被摧毁了
and are desperate to start new lives as miners, as homesteaders, as farmers, in what they are beginning to see. People have dismissed the Great Plains for decades, but now people are sort of saying, well, maybe this is the promised land. Maybe we can start new lives out here. Now, the fact that there are some people there already. Yeah, that's the relevance. Who cares about that?
并且渴望开始新的生活，作为矿工、宅地主、农民，在他们开始看到的地方。几十年来人们一直不屑于大平原，但现在人们开始说，好吧，也许这是应许之地。也许我们可以在这里开始新的生活。现在，事实上那里已经有一些人了。是啊，这就是相关性。谁在乎那个？
Well, exactly. And also the prospect of finding gold. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's all very well setting cares about that? Well, exactly. And also the prospect of finding gold. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's all very well setting up a farm. Yes, of course. But if you can go and find a large lump of gold, that's even better. Because if you're 40 in 1873, pretty much all your life,
嗯，完全正确。还有发现黄金的前景。哦，是的。是啊。我的意思是，建立一个农场固然很好。是的，当然。但如果你能去找到一大块黄金，那就更好了。因为如果你在1873年40岁，几乎你的一生，
certainly all your life that you can remember, you've grown up in a world of gold rushes. California, Colorado, there's been talk of gold in Oregon, all of these kinds of places. So you dream of a new gold rush where you can be rich overnight as people were in the California gold rush in the late 1840s and 1850s. So that's hanging over this whole thing. Maybe the Great Plains have these amazing untapped resources. And there's one place, isn't there, in particular, that it's thought that there might be gold,
当然是你记得的所有一生，你都是在淘金热的世界中长大的。加利福尼亚、科罗拉多，有关于俄勒冈淘金的传言，所有这些地方。所以你梦想着一场新的淘金热，在那里你可以一夜暴富，就像1840年代末和1850年代加州淘金热中的人们一样。所以这笼罩着整件事。也许大平原拥有这些惊人的未开发资源。有一个地方，不是吗，特别被认为可能有黄金，
and this is a place called the Black Hills. The Black Hills. The reason they end up in the Black Hills, first of all, is actually because Sheridan wants a fort there. So the Black Hills are just outside the Great Sioux Reservation. People may remember in the last episode, well, when we talked about the deal that had been done with Red Cloud, the American government had given Lakota this big reservation,
这个地方叫黑山。黑山。他们最终进入黑山的原因，首先实际上是因为谢里丹想要在那里建一个堡垒。所以黑山就在大苏族保留地外面。人们可能还记得上一集，嗯，当我们谈到与红云达成的协议时，美国政府给了拉科塔人这个大保留地，
the Great Sioux Reservation, covering much of South Dakota. But they said that all the land, basically to the west of it, was what was called unceded Indian territory, which is a kind of grey area. You know, the army can kind of go in, but they need to get permission. Is it Indian? Is it American? Anyway anyway sheridan wants to build a fort there he doesn't like the fact the sitting bull and the non-treaty indians as they're called are kind of roaming around and are a little bit kind of disputatious and stuff and are fighting the crows and stuff he wants to kind of sort this out and regularize it he says i, I'd really like a fort in the Black Hills, or just right next to the Black Hills. Now, the Black Hills, the Pahasapa,
大苏族保留地，覆盖了南达科他州的大部分地区。但他们说，基本上西边的所有土地都是所谓的“未割让的印第安领土”，这是一种灰色地带。你知道，军队可以进去，但他们需要获得许可。它是印第安的吗？它是美国的吗？总之，总之，谢里丹想在那里建一个堡垒。他不喜欢坐牛和所谓的“非条约印第安人”在周围游荡，而且有点好争论，还在和乌鸦族人打仗之类的。他想整理一下，使之正规化。他说，我真的想要在黑山，或者就在黑山旁边建一个堡垒。现在，黑山，帕哈萨帕，
as they are called, everybody thinks they're sacred to the Lakota. Right. So I had always thought that. Yeah, I did too. I'd always assumed this. I mean, this is the timeless of you know the the timeless spirit world of right the lakota kind of stuff that i had completely bought into i mean basically they've they've been there three or four decades something like that and they've nicked them off is it the crow or the shayan i can't remember yeah exactly they'd fought for them they're actually more sacred they are sacred to the shayan they are sacred to shayan aren't they But not really to the Lakota. The issue for the Lakota is, A, we've conquered them.
正如他们所称的那样，每个人都认为它们对拉科塔人来说是神圣的。对。所以我一直这么认为。是啊，我也这么认为。我一直以为是这样。我的意思是，这是永恒的……你知道，永恒的精神世界，拉科塔人的那种东西，我完全相信了。我的意思是，基本上他们已经在那里待了三四十年了，差不多就是这样，他们从……是乌鸦族还是夏延族那里偷来的？我不记得了。是啊，完全正确，他们为之战斗。它们实际上更神圣，它们对夏延族来说是神圣的，它们对夏延族来说是神圣的，不是吗？但对拉科塔人来说并不是真的。对拉科塔人来说的问题是，A，我们征服了它们。
They're ours. It's ours. And I mean, the Lakota would say, hold on, that's how the United States thinks. Yeah, of course. They think that when they conquer something, it's theirs. This is our thing. We should keep it. They'd only conquered it a few decades before.
它们是我们的。它是我们的。我的意思是，拉科塔人会说，等等，美国人就是这么想的。是啊，当然。他们认为当他们征服了某样东西时，它就是他们的。这是我们的东西。我们应该保留它。他们只是在几十年前才征服了它。
That's the thing. Of course they had. And they would reasonably say, well, I mean, that's true of the United States. Yeah, sure. But it's not primordially since the beginning of time, since the great spirit gave to them kind of stuff. No, totally. So everybody who thinks, you know,
就是这样。当然他们是这样。他们会合理地说，嗯，我的意思是，这对美国来说也是真的。是啊，当然。但它并不是从时间之初，从大灵赐予他们那种东西以来就原始存在的。不，完全不是。所以每个人都认为，你知道，
these were men and women of the earth. Yeah. Their timeless spirituality was rooted in the Black Hills. That's tosh and rubbish. And what they really want it for is it's very, very rich in buffalo. So there are kind of sheltered meadows where the buffalo can kind of graze, but there are also loads of pine trees, which they use for their kind of poles and their lodges and stuff.
这些是大地上的男人和女人。是啊。他们永恒的灵性植根于黑山。那是胡说八道。他们真正想要它是因为那里野牛非常非常多。所以有一些有遮蔽的草地，野牛可以在那里吃草，但也有大量的松树，他们用这些松树做他们的杆子和帐篷之类的东西。
That sounds lovely. It's brilliant for them. Tyrannosaurs as well? Tyrannosaur skeletons? Are there good dinosaurs in the Black Hills, Tom? Yeah, really good. Yeah. Wonderful.
听起来很可爱。这对他们来说太棒了。还有暴龙吗？暴龙骨架？黑山有好的恐龙吗，汤姆？是啊，真的很好。是啊。太棒了。
So the Lakota are very displeased at any talk of the Black Hills, Tom? Yeah, really good. Yeah, wonderful. So the Lakota are very displeased at any talk of the Black Hills being taken from them. And of course, Sheridan, so he needs to send out a survey mission. Where are we going to put the fort? And the person he sends out is Custer. Custer goes with 10 companies
所以拉科塔人对任何关于黑山被从他们手中夺走的谈话都非常不满，汤姆？是啊，真的很好。是啊，太棒了。所以拉科塔人对任何关于黑山被从他们手中夺走的谈话都非常不满。当然，谢里丹，所以他需要派出一个勘测任务。我们要把堡垒建在哪里？他派出去的人是卡斯特。卡斯特带着10个连
of the 7th Cavalry. They've got Gatling guns, they have scouts, they have scientists, they have geologists, Tom. They have fossil hunters. And President Grant's son, Fred, goes along too because he thinks this sounds brilliant. What a great laugh this will be going to the Black Hills. And loads of newspapermen go.
的第7骑兵团去了。他们有加特林机枪，他们有侦察兵，他们有科学家，他们有地质学家，汤姆。他们有化石猎人。总统格兰特的儿子弗雷德也跟着去了，因为他认为这听起来太棒了。去黑山会是一件多么有趣的事。还有很多报纸记者也去了。
And at this point, Custer's activities in the West have become a great media sensation. Well, he pays up to it, doesn't he? Of course. It's really important. Sheridan tends to say to Custer, please don't take too many journalists. Yeah, he does. And so Custer's response to this is to recruit a few more. Yeah. I mean, Custer is given so many opportunities by his superiors, isn't he?
在这一点上，卡斯特在西部的活动已经成为一个巨大的媒体轰动。嗯，他为此付出了代价，不是吗？当然。这非常重要。谢里丹倾向于对卡斯特说，请不要带太多记者。是啊，他确实这么说了。所以卡斯特对此的回应是再招募几个。是啊。我的意思是，卡斯特的上级给了他这么多机会，不是吗？
Sheridan is so tolerant of him. Custer keeps letting him down. I think it's that quote from Ian Frazier that we had about 20 episodes ago. I mean, I think it does kind of capture something about it. It's fun. Custer is the kind of embodiment of what these desk-occupying political generals dealing with an industrial army, as children maybe imagined being a soldier would be like. Dashing around on cavalry, leading expeditions, all that kind of thing.
谢里丹对他非常宽容。卡斯特不断让他失望。我想那是我们大约20集前引用的伊恩·弗雷泽的那句话。我的意思是，我认为它确实捕捉到了关于它的一些东西。这很有趣。卡斯特是那些处理工业化军队的坐办公室的政治将军们，作为孩子可能想象中士兵的样子的一种化身。在骑兵上冲来冲去，领导远征，所有那种事情。
I think they indulge him because people do sometimes indulge characters, don't they? And I think you're absolutely right. And he's good for the reputation of the army, isn't he? And he's got lots of credit from the Civil War. And the Civil War, we shouldn't underestimate how important the civil war is. The civil war, arguably the world's first industrial war, seismic psychological impact. If you've got a good war record, as almost all the politicians of these decades do, then that will get you a very long way. Custer can trade for years on his record in the civil war.
我想他们纵容他，因为人们有时确实会纵容角色，不是吗？我认为你绝对是对的。而且他对军队的声誉有好处，不是吗？而且他在内战中获得了很多功劳。内战，我们不应该低估内战的重要性。内战，可以说是世界上第一次工业战争，地震般的心理影响。如果你有良好的战争记录，正如这几十年的几乎所有政治家所拥有的那样，那么这会让你走得很远。卡斯特可以凭他在内战中的记录交易多年。
But also journalists yeah so you quote here the young william e curtis who writes of custer he's a great man a noble man is general custer i mean he's not a general is he i mean that's important to say he was a general but he's now what i think colonel lieutenant or something if that's such a thing then there is such a thing as a colonel lieutenant and actually were this an american podcast tom they would undoubtedly know that detail they would i don't know but he's not a general i mean that's the salient point yeah his wife a charming lady who has shared his marches and victories since early in the war is as gentle and cultivated and yet as soldierly as a woman can be i mean it's so like buckets of syrup being
但还有记者，是啊，所以你在这里引用了年轻的威廉·E·柯蒂斯，他写道卡斯特：“他是一个伟大的人，一个高尚的人，卡斯特将军。”我的意思是，他不是将军，不是吗？我的意思是，说这一点很重要，他曾经是将军，但他现在是什么，我想是中校还是什么，如果真有那种东西的话。确实有中校这种东西，而且实际上如果这是一个美国播客，汤姆，他们无疑会知道那个细节。他们会，我不知道，但他不是将军，我的意思是那是重点。是啊，他的妻子，一位迷人的女士，自战争初期就分享了他的行军和胜利，她像一个女人所能做到的那样温柔、有教养，却又像士兵一样。我的意思是，这就像几桶糖浆被
poured over custer that same guy who's from the from the Chicago interocean, and he also reports for the New York World. He said, one day I went in to find Custer, and he was with two little girls, one white and one black, teaching them to read. And it's just such an unbelievably implausible, clearly untrue story. But also, I mean, Custer, he gives good copy. He does. So when he rides off on the Black, Custer, he gives good copy. He does. So when he rides off on the Black Hills expedition, he takes a band. Yeah. They kind of canter off playing Gary Owen.
倒在卡斯特身上。那个来自芝加哥《国际海洋报》的家伙，他也为《纽约世界报》报道。他说，有一天我进去找卡斯特，他和两个小女孩在一起，一个白人一个黑人，教她们读书。这只是一个令人难以置信的、显然不真实的故事。但也，我的意思是，卡斯特，他提供了很好的稿件。他确实。所以当他骑马去黑山时，卡斯特，他提供了很好的稿件。他确实。所以当他骑马去黑山远征时，他带了一个乐队。是啊。他们一边演奏《加里·欧文》一边小跑着离开。
Yeah. And every morning when they break camp, the band serenades the troops to get them in a kind of marching spirit. Yeah, he loves all that stuff, doesn't he? Very Walter Scott. Calamity Jane is there? This is an interesting thing, Tom. This is a great example of the myth making that surrounds this whole thing because actually calamity jane may well not have been there oh what but she later says that she was there oh oh dominic you and your myth busting so it's just like with sitting bull though later on when he
是啊。每天早上他们拆营时，乐队都会为部队演奏小夜曲，让他们进入一种行军精神。是啊，他喜欢所有那些东西，不是吗？非常沃尔特·司各特。卡拉米蒂·简也在那里？这是一个有趣的事情，汤姆。这是围绕整件事的神话制造的一个很好的例子，因为实际上卡拉米蒂·简很可能根本不在那里。哦，什么？但她后来确实说她在那里。哦，哦，多米尼克，你和你的神话粉碎。所以这就像坐牛一样，虽然后来当他
joins buffalo bill's show everything to do with this period and everything to do with the West, even as it is happening, is being merchandised and kind of commodified for readers in the suburbs of cities on the East Coast. So it's actually really hard sometimes to work out who's there and who isn't, what's going on, because there's so much fiction being created even at the time. And that's what's so fascinating about the arc of Custer's story, is that it's not that his death then results in a kind of backward-looking mythologization. It's almost the other way around. It's the fact that Custer has been mythologized in the years before that makes makes his end the perfect climax really it does the perfect end to the story it does it absolutely so off they go anyway into the black hills and actually the lakota are nowhere to be found they're off hunting buffalo most of them sitting bull is crazy horse so he had a very checkered
加入布法罗·比尔的表演时，与这一时期有关的一切，与西部有关的一切，即使在它发生时，也被商品化并为东海岸城市郊区的读者所消费。所以有时真的很难弄清楚谁在那里，谁不在那里，发生了什么，因为即使在当时也有太多的虚构被创造出来。这就是卡斯特故事的弧线如此迷人的地方，不是说他的死导致了一种回顾性的神话化。几乎是反过来的。正是卡斯特在之前几年被神话化的事实，使得他的结局成为了完美的巅峰，真的。它确实是故事的完美结局，它确实是。绝对是。所以无论如何，他们出发进入黑山，实际上拉科塔人无处可寻，他们大多数人都在外面猎杀野牛，坐牛是疯马，所以他有一段非常坎坷的
romantic history he tried to steal the wife of another man hadn't he and got in terrible trouble and been stripped of his sort of offices isn't that right some complicated story like that but i'm sure he behaves very well throughout yeah right and then he gets a wife and they have a daughter but the age of i think two or three or something she dies of cholera and he then takes loads of time off and goes and mourns alone out on the plains and stuff. So he's nowhere to be seen, which is great for Custer because Custer, one historian says,
浪漫历史。他试图偷走另一个人的妻子，不是吗？并陷入了可怕的麻烦，被剥夺了他的某种职位，不是吗？一些类似那样的复杂故事，但我确信他在整个过程中表现得非常好。是啊，对。然后他得到了一个妻子，他们有一个女儿，但在两三岁左右，她死于霍乱，然后他请了很长时间假，独自去平原上哀悼之类的。所以他无处可寻，这对卡斯特来说太棒了，因为卡斯特，一位历史学家说，
the expedition took on the aspect of an armed picnic. So every day, I mean, they're picking flowers. Yeah, beautiful meadows. Doing all that. Custer kills a grizzly bear. That's so Custer. Which he thinks is very enjoyable. And he could make a gift of the grease from the bear to the crow for their pomade.
这次远征呈现出一种武装野餐的样子。所以每天，我的意思是，他们在采花。是啊，美丽的草地。做所有那些事。卡斯特杀了一只灰熊。那太卡斯特了。他认为这非常令人愉快。他可以把熊的油脂作为礼物送给乌鸦族人，作为他们的发蜡。
He could, to do it for their hair. And maybe for old time's sake, remembering his time at West Point when he put creams in his hair, he might have put some of that bear grease in his own hair, Tom. We don't know, do we? Yeah, maybe. Cinnamon. creams in his hair he might have put some of that bare grease in his own hair tom we don't know who do we yeah maybe cinnamon i think at this point it's probably apparent to custer that his hair is not quite what it was it is starting to retreat isn't it it is retreating and that's important because later on it'll mean it's very difficult to scalp him because he doesn't have any hair anyway end of july 1874 they're in the black hills and suddenly they find the one thing
他可以，为了他们的头发。也许为了旧时光，记得他在西点军校时在头发里抹奶油的时光，他可能在自己的头发里抹了一些那种熊油，汤姆。我们不知道，不是吗？是啊，也许。肉桂。在头发里抹奶油，他可能在自己的头发里抹了一些那种熊油，汤姆。我们不知道，不是吗？是啊，也许。肉桂。我想在这一点上，卡斯特可能很清楚他的头发已经不如从前了。它开始后退了，不是吗？它正在后退，这很重要，因为后来这意味着很难剥他的头皮，因为他反正也没有头发。1874年7月底，他们在黑山，突然他们发现了他们梦想发现的一件事，
that they had dreamed of finding it's gold so they brought two miners with them the miners have a little dig and the scouts describe how suddenly they see people weeping shouting throwing their hats in the air ye Yee-haw! Exactly. The miners say, we've found a bit of gold. Now, actually, they haven't really found very much. They've found this sort of pitiful trace of gold. But of course, because of the panic of 1873, because of the Depression, people really want to believe it.
那就是黄金。所以他们带了两个矿工。矿工们挖了一点，侦察兵描述了他们如何突然看到人们哭泣、尖叫、把帽子扔向空中。“耶！嘿！”正是如此。矿工们说：“我们发现了一点黄金。”现在，实际上，他们并没有真正发现很多。他们发现了这种可怜的黄金痕迹。但当然，因为1873年的恐慌，因为大萧条，人们真的想相信它。
The newspapers have been saying, please find gold. Please tell us you've found some gold. They find the gold, and then the newspapers are kind of gold. These huge headlines struck it at last. Prepare for lively times and all this kind of thing. Rush. Hurry while stocks last. Now, the irony is Custer actually never finds a place for this fort.
报纸一直在说，请发现黄金。请告诉我们你们发现了一些黄金。他们发现了黄金，然后报纸就……黄金。这些巨大的标题：“终于发现了。”“准备迎接热闹的时光”以及所有这类事情。“冲啊。”“趁库存还有时赶快。”现在，讽刺的是，卡斯特实际上从未为这个堡垒找到一个地方。
So the fort had been sent out to find. Oh, yeah. Well, who cares about that? He's like, no, there's probably no way where the fort that had been sent out to find oh yeah well who cares about that like he's like no there's probably nowhere where the fort can go but guster himself as his biographers put it comes down with gold fever and it's partly not just because he likes the idea of gold but it's actually because he all his life has given newspapermen the copy that they wanted and so when they the journalists say to him you know is there is there gold he says yeah loads yes sir yeah yeah you betcha loads of gold couldn't be more gold
所以堡垒被派出去寻找。哦，是的。嗯，谁在乎那个？他就像，不，可能没有地方可以放堡垒，但卡斯特本人，正如他的传记作者所说，患上了“淘金热”。这部分不仅是因为他喜欢黄金的想法，而且实际上是因为他一生都给了报纸记者他们想要的稿件，所以当记者问他，你知道，有没有黄金，他说：“是啊，很多。”“是的，先生，是啊，你打赌，很多黄金，不可能有更多黄金了。”
actually the geologists even at this point saying hold on fred grant who's gone on they you know this sort of gap year type thing the son of u Ulysses. The son of the president. Yeah. He gets back and he says, this is not cold at all. I don't know what they're talking about. But it's much too late because by the time it's appeared in the East Coast newspapers,
实际上，即使在这一点上，地质学家也说，等等，弗雷德·格兰特，他去了，他们，你知道，这种间隔年类型的事情，尤利西斯的儿子。总统的儿子。是啊。他回来后说，这根本不是黄金。我不知道他们在说什么。但已经太晚了，因为当它出现在东海岸报纸上时，
people are pouring into the Black Hills. And obviously this is bad news for the Lakota. Oh, it's terrible news for the Lakota. It's really, really bad news for the Lakota. And Sheridan, at first, sort of says, hey, whoa, whoa, keep them out.
人们正涌入黑山。显然这对拉科塔人来说是个坏消息。哦，这对拉科塔人来说是个可怕的消息。这对拉科塔人来说真是非常、非常糟糕的消息。谢里丹，起初，有点说，嘿，哇，哇，把他们挡在外面。
They shouldn't be coming. You know, this is going to cause tremendous difficulties. But it's not really possible. The general who gets to do it is a guy called General Crook. He will come up later on, Tom, at the Battle of the Little Bighorn.
他们不应该来。你知道，这会造成巨大的困难。但这真的不可能。得到这个任务的将军是一个叫克鲁克将军的人。他稍后会出现，汤姆，在小大角战役中。
He will. Bizarrely. I mean, all these strange relationships among the generals. He had been Sheridan's roommate. Did you see this at West Point? Yeah. And they'd fallen out and were not on speaking terms anymore.
他会的。奇怪的是。我的意思是，将军们之间所有这些奇怪的关系。他曾经是谢里丹的室友。你看到了吗？在西点军校。是啊。他们闹翻了，不再说话了。
Well, so Evan Connell has a brilliant description of Crook. And more beard action, Dominic. With a nose like a knife and his split beard, he looks undeniably imperial, much like Lucas Cranach's portrait of Augustus, Grand Duke of Saxony. So that's taking us back to our Luther episode. So I believe that General Crook used to have his beard in kind of braids. He's like a kind of angry badger. That doesn't inspire any confidence in me, a braided beard.
嗯，所以埃文·康奈尔对克鲁克有一个精彩的描述。还有更多的胡子动作，多米尼克。有着像刀一样的鼻子和分叉的胡子，他看起来不可否认地具有帝国气息，很像卢卡斯·克拉纳赫的萨克森大公奥古斯都的肖像。所以这把我们带回了我们的路德那一集。所以我相信克鲁克将军过去常把他的胡子编成辫子。他就像一只愤怒的獾。这对我没有任何信心，编辫子的胡子。
I'll tell you that now. But he's a very astute and experienced. Indian fighter. Indian fighter, isn't he? He is indeed. But they can't keep out this flood of people. So this is now putting enormous pressure on the sort of existing political ecosystem, as it were, of this area.
我现在就告诉你。但他是一个非常精明和有经验的印第安战士。印第安战士，不是吗？他确实是。但他们无法挡住这股人潮。所以这现在给这个地区的现有政治生态系统带来了巨大的压力。
And while all this is happening, the fact that the Americans have been messing around at all in the Black Hills is extremely disturbing to the Cheyenne, because the Cheyenne take the Black Hills very seriously. And they're like, what's going on here so it's in that context that in the summer of 1875 Sitting Bull says to the Cheyenne listen why don't we all get together we're clearly facing you know a real challenge maybe have a sun dance we should have a sun dance so they meet, and they meet actually at Rosebud Creek, Tom. Yeah, which will be playing a part in the story to come.
当这一切发生时，美国人在黑山乱搞的事实对夏延族来说是非常令人不安的，因为夏延族非常认真地对待黑山。他们就像，这里发生了什么？所以就是在这种背景下，在1875年的夏天，坐牛对夏延族说：“听着，为什么我们不聚在一起？我们显然面临着，你知道，一个真正的挑战，也许举行一次太阳舞，我们应该举行一次太阳舞。”所以他们见面了，他们实际上在玫瑰花蕾溪见面，汤姆。是啊，这将在未来的故事中发挥作用。
So they put a big display on the Lakota for the Cheyenne to kind of please them. And the Sitting Bull, he dances with a pony. He smokes pipes with the chiefs of the Cheyenne and the Hunkpapa. He's dancing. He does loads of dancing. He does a sort of mime of an ambush. He mimes an ambush, doesn't he? Yeah.
所以他们为夏延族展示了拉科塔人的大场面，以取悦他们。坐牛，他带着一匹小马跳舞。他和夏延族和洪克帕帕族的酋长们抽烟斗。他在跳舞。他跳了很多舞。他做了一种伏击的哑剧。他模仿了一次伏击，不是吗？是啊。
He does. And then he sort of shouts out, the great spirit has given our enemy into our power. And then he says again, the great spirit has given our enemies to us. We are to destroy them. And all this kind of thing. So clearly they're gearing up. They're gearing up for a big one. They know that there's this sort of dribble.
他确实。然后他大喊：“大灵已经把我们的敌人交到了我们的权力之下。”然后他又说：“大灵已经把我们的敌人交给了我们。我们要消灭他们。”以及所有这类事情。所以显然他们正在准备。他们正在为一场大战做准备。他们知道有这种涓涓细流。
It's more than a dribble. It's a trickle of rogues, ruffians, rascals, speculators, frontier men, all that kind of stuff. Oh, my God. What was that? That was the noise of a frontiersman. That's a frontiersman discovering gold, Dominic. Wow.
这不仅仅是涓涓细流。这是一群流氓、恶棍、无赖、投机者、边境人，所有这类东西。哦，我的天。那是什么？那是边境人的声音。那是边境人发现了黄金，多米尼克。哇。
That is terrifying. That's what they sounded like. Okay. Well, they're arriving. And frankly, if I heard that. You'd run, wouldn't you? I wouldn't run. No.
那太可怕了。那就是他们听起来的样子。好吧。嗯，他们正在到达。坦率地说，如果我听到那个。你会跑，不是吗？我不会跑。不。
But that's because you're not a Lakota brave or you prepare for war. I would prepare for war. The storm clouds of war would be gathering right there at some point. I mean, they're massive. Because the thing is that Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse and everyone around them, everything they're about is saying, we're going to fight. And now they've got all these people flooding towards them. Of course they're going to fight. I mean, this is, as you say, the storm clouds of war are gathering. They are indeed. So first of all, President Grant in the autumn
但那是因为你不是拉科塔勇士，或者你为战争做准备。我会为战争做准备。战争的乌云就在那里聚集。我的意思是，它们是巨大的。因为事实是，坐牛和疯马以及他们周围的每个人，他们所做的一切都在说，我们要战斗。现在他们有所有这些人涌向他们。当然他们会战斗。我的意思是，正如你所说，战争的乌云正在聚集。它们确实是。所以首先，格兰特总统在秋天
of 1875, remember he's had his peace policy. Remember, his whole policy has been about not having war, but about encouraging the Plains Indians to assimilate. He sends a commission under Iowa Senator William B. Allison. The vast majority of the people on this commission know absolutely nothing of the West or of the Plains peoples at all. The only one who does is a man called General Terry, who is the overall commander in the Dakota Territory. He will definitely be featuring. He's a very smooth operator. He is, but he has another tremendous beard. A big theme of this series. Yeah, well, because they've all got beards. They've all got beards. But he's a master of giving ambiguous instructions, isn't he?
1875年，记住他有他的和平政策。记住，他的整个政策一直是不打仗，而是鼓励平原印第安人同化。他派出了一个委员会，由爱荷华州参议员威廉·B·艾利森领导。这个委员会上的绝大多数人对西部或平原民族一无所知。唯一知道的是一个叫特里将军的人，他是达科他领地的总指挥官。他肯定会出场。他是一个非常圆滑的人。他是，但他有另一把巨大的胡子。这个系列的一个大主题。是啊，嗯，因为他们都有胡子。他们都有胡子。但他是一个给出模糊指令的大师，不是吗？
He is indeed. I quite like General Terry. I admire his intelligence, his political intelligence. Anyway, this commission arrive at the Red Cloud Agency, and they have been sent basically to buy the hills from the Lakota. And they invite everybody to come. They invite Crazy Horse, they invite Sitting Bull. Crazy Horse says, you know, I'm not going to come and talk to you. I'd rather fight you. Sitting Bull, supposedly when he's invited, he picks up a little pinch of dirt, of soil, and he says, I wouldn't even sell this to you. You know, I'm not coming. And the issue is not because the hills are sacred. It is because they have been conquered by the Lakota, and it is a humiliation to give them away. That's the real issue, that politically it would be disastrous for Lakota leaders to give up their conquest so meekly. Because otherwise all their talk about refusing to surrender would look like so much hot air, wouldn't it?
他确实是。我相当喜欢特里将军。我钦佩他的智慧，他的政治智慧。总之，这个委员会到达了红云代理处，他们基本上被派去从拉科塔人手中购买山脉。他们邀请所有人来。他们邀请疯马，他们邀请坐牛。疯马说：“你知道，我不会来和你谈话。我宁愿和你打仗。”坐牛，据说当他被邀请时，他抓起一小撮泥土，土壤，他说：“我甚至不会把它卖给你。你知道，我不来。”问题不是因为山脉是神圣的。是因为它们被拉科塔人征服了，把它们送人是一种羞辱。这就是真正的问题，在政治上，拉科塔领导人如此温顺地放弃他们的征服将是灾难性的。因为否则他们关于拒绝投降的所有谈话看起来就像是空话，不是吗？
Of course it would. Of course it would. So this council opens, Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse, a lot of their kind of supporters actually go to intimidate the other chiefs and to say, you make a deal and we will kill you. I mean, that's literally what they say. But actually, the chiefs have no intention of selling the hills.
当然会。当然会。所以这个委员会开幕了，坐牛和疯马，他们的许多支持者实际上去恐吓其他酋长，并说：“你们达成协议，我们就杀了你们。”我的意思是，这字面上就是他们说的。但实际上，酋长们根本没有打算卖掉山脉。
Spotted Tail, who is their spokesman, says to the commissioners, we will sell them if you give us money that will sustain us for seven generations. I'm talking about 60 million dollars i mean that's obviously billions and billions in today's money and the commissioners kind of their blood drains from their faces because they've been authorized to offer about five million dollars four beans yeah so the talks break up and the commissioners go back home and they say the lakota are clearly not going to compromise at all on this. And they say what they recommend is that Congress should decide arbitrarily itself a price, offer it to the Indians,
斑点尾，他们的发言人对委员们说：“如果我们卖掉它们，你们给我们足以维持我们七代人的钱。”我说的是6000万美元，我的意思是那在今天的钱里显然是几十亿几十亿。委员们有点……他们的血从脸上流干了，因为他们被授权提供大约500万美元。四颗豆子。是啊。所以谈判破裂了，委员们回家了，他们说拉科塔人显然根本不会在这件事上妥协。他们说他们建议国会应该自己武断地决定一个价格，提供给印第安人，
and then if the Indians say no, that they should cut off all supplies to the reservations and basically starve them out. So now Grant has this dilemma. What's he going to do? Is he going to follow that? Is he going to go for just war instead? Just go straight to the war option? Or is he going to let the issue lie and have peace, which is in keeping with his rhetoric earlier in his presidency?
然后如果印第安人说不，他们应该切断对保留地的所有补给，基本上把他们饿死。所以现在格兰特面临这个困境。他要怎么做？他是要遵循那个吗？他是要直接选择战争吗？直接选择战争选项？还是他要让这个问题搁置并保持和平，这与他总统任期早期的言论相符？
It could have done. The issue, though, Tom, is the panic of 1873 and the economic depression means he is under far more political pressure than he would have been otherwise, because all the time, all these sort of miners are on their way. So Dominic, who's going to have a greater influence on him, an angry, needy electorate or the Lakota? That's the question, isn't it? Well, we'll find out because on the 3rd of November 1875, Grant says, says okay let's settle this
本来可以做到的。然而，问题是，汤姆，1873年的恐慌和经济萧条意味着他承受的政治压力比他本来会承受的要大得多，因为一直以来，所有这些矿工都在路上。所以多米尼克，谁对他会有更大的影响，一个愤怒、贫困的选民还是拉科塔人？这就是问题，不是吗？嗯，我们会发现，因为在1875年11月3日，格兰特说，说好吧，让我们解决这个问题
and he calls at the white house general crook and general sheridan and some of his other sort of top officials to a secret meeting tom and the subject of this secret meeting will be peace or war and on the outcome of this meeting hangs the fate of the Lakota and the life of George Armstrong Custer. What a cliffhanger. And if you want to find out what happens, will there be war? What will happen to the Lakota? What will happen to Custer? Who knows?
他在白宫召集了克鲁克将军和谢里丹将军以及他的一些其他高级官员开了一个秘密会议，汤姆。这次秘密会议的主题将是和平还是战争，这次会议的结果决定了拉科塔人的命运和乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特的生命。多么悬念。如果你想知道发生了什么，会有战争吗？拉科塔人会发生什么？卡斯特会发生什么？谁知道呢？
If you want to find out, you can listen right away. Either if you're already a club member, if you're not, you can go rest is history.com and sign up there or you can wait our next episode it will be the build-up to the battle of the little bighorn then we will have the battle of the little bighorn itself maybe in one episode maybe in two who knows we're so into this story that it's just spiraling out of control and then we will be looking at the aftermath of it up to the tragic story of the ghost dance. Yeah, very exciting times. So, lots still to come. I mean, this is really building up to an extraordinary climax.
如果你想知道，你可以马上听。如果你已经是俱乐部会员，如果你不是，你可以去restishistory.com注册，或者你可以等我们的下一集，那将是小大角战役的铺垫，然后我们将有小大角战役本身，也许在一集里，也许在两集里，谁知道呢？我们太沉迷于这个故事了，它只是失控了，然后我们将看看它的后果，直到鬼舞的悲剧故事。是啊，非常激动人心的时刻。所以，还有很多要来。我的意思是，这真的在建立一个非凡的巅峰。
You don't want to miss it. Thanks so much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
你不想错过它。非常感谢收听。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。